depuis cette année le climat n'a jamais
été autant préoccupant vague de chaleur
absolument inédite chaque jour il fait
un peu plus au travers de plusieurs
canicule sas annonceurs alors que le
mois d'avril et de mai ont enregistré
des températures record la france
clairement va cramer ce week-end les
prévisions météo sont alarmantes jamais
de mémoire de météorologues une
vigilance rouge à la canicule n'avait
été déclenchée aussi tôt dans l'année
douze départements sont en vigilance
rouge avec des températures dépassant
les 40 degrés dans certaines villes on
va atteindre 41 degrés vers la partie à
midi pyrénées alors que des incendies
frappe actuellement la majeure partie de
l'espagne le réchauffement climatique
laisse craindre le pire à leurs
prévisions à 50° record inquiétant
incendie y at il urgence à s'inquiéter
voilà c'est le gros gros sujet du jour
on va accueillir nos invités car
ignorant bonsoir bonsoir de spécialistes
métérologiques des phénomènes météo
extrêmes extrême voilà et sasha vous
êtes déjà venu nous voir parce que hélas
pour la personne qui s'est approché
à roland-garros au filet pour un pour
signifier qu'il restait que 1000 28
jours maintenant il fait un peu moins
avant que ce soit la catastrophe on va
regarder quand même parce que en ce
moment c'est traiter de façon assez
différents et les gens qui font la météo
parfois ils ont envie de vous [ __ ] un
peu la trouille regardez et voici les
températures prévues pour cet après midi
qui ont été revus ce matin quand même un
petit peu à la baisse il fera jusqu'à 39
degrés pour montpellier pour toulouse ou
encore pour bordeaux ce sera quand même
trente sept pour nantes 35 degrés pour
paris le minimum 29 degrés tout de même
et ce sera pour la côte d'azur pour la
journée de demain le flux de secteur sud
sera encore plus présent important
encore plus de chaleur et ce même sur la
moitié nord 41 attendu pour bordeaux 41
également pour auxerre on aura 40 degrés
à bourges au mans ainsi que du côté de
poitiers ce sera trente neuf pour la
capitale et on retrouvera un tout petit
peu plus de fraîcheur près de la manche
avec la 27 degrés c'est incroyable c'est
incroyable alors certains prédisent la
fin du monde quand même elle concéda est
ce que c'est possible cette fin du monde
à cause des températures en tout cas
c'est ce sont de gros changements qui
vont intervenir au cours des prochaines
années et le problème c'est que ces
changements vont intervenir bien plus
vite que ce qu'on croyait dix ou quinze
ans serait que les prévisions de
changement climatique on était vraiment
totalement revue changement climatique
s'accélère bien plus que ce qu'on
croyait avec un exemple si tu as un
degré de réchauffement par rapport aux
niveaux pré industriels
et on se dirige vers les 1 degré 5 de
réchauffement d'ici 5 6 ans peut-être
selon l'onu alors en 2003 il y avait
émis dahlia qui avait fait une météo et
le jury ce mois ci dans ça n'arrivera
peut-être mis la main c'est un terme
2050 regardez ce qu'elle a fait comme
carte et ben en fait on y est à nous
parce qu'on aime regarder
[Musique]
madame monsieur bonsoir encore de fortes
chaleurs en ce 17 août 2050 avec un
soleil de plomb demain matin les
températures seront déjà très élevé
notamment à paris à perpignan ou à nice
avec 26 degrés et dans l'après midi on
atteindra ou dépassera encore les 40° 41
juin 41 strasbourg 40 dans la capitale
quarante deux pour lyon et jusqu'à 43
degrés prévus à nîmes à la coop alors
elle a expliqué on est on est quasiment
dans les mêmes températures en baisse et
bise aux garçons vite ça arrive c'est ce
qu'on l'envoie demain qu'est ce qui fait
que ce ça s'est accéléré à ce point est
ce qu'on parle le le carbone est ce que
c'est vraiment ça alors ya plus aucun
doute un peu comment ça suce
scientifique sur les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre qui sont responsables en
casino corps d'état lionel avions les
bateaux voilà les centrales de charbon
voilà donc concrètement est-ce que c'est
trop tard vous parler en privé avec avec
sacha mais est ce que c'est il ya plus
rien à faire et pourquoi pas quelque
chose est ce que vraiment comme ça tu en
dises il va faire 50 degrés sachant que
rousset qui à 50 degrés on peut pas
vivre c'est très compliqué alors les 50
degrés sont plus en plus probable pour
le futur pas tout de suite évidemment le
record c'est 46 en france quand même
c'est déjà pas mal ce temps de 19 pour
le futur oui on se dirige vers des
prévisions assez alarmiste on prend pas
le bon chemin d'une coupe du tout
évidemment après il ya quand même
beaucoup de choses à faire pour lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique on
connaît la cause déjà c'est une bonne
chose donc y'a plus qu'à mettre en
oeuvre et ça passe par une réduction
drastique des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre l'onu parle d'une réduction de
43 % d'ici 2030 qui est nécessaire donc
c'est énorme est ce que vous pensez
juste rebondir parce que le podium le
futur c'est f1 c'est exact mais le futur
qu'est ce que c'est c'est pas 50 ans
futur c to c business et c'est dans dix
ans il ya un milliard de personnes sur
les routes donc c'est pas un futur
éloigné et je vous entendez rigoler
quand on voyait 40 degrés et vous savez
ce que ça veut dire 40 degrés bah ça
fait chaud mais ça veut dire qu'il ya
plus rien qui pousse ses besoins qu'on
peut pas vivre là bas c'est ça qui va
réaliser comment se passait dans 20 à 30
ans toute l'amérique centrale c'est fini
une bonne partie de l'afrique
l'australie l'asie du sud est on peut
plus y vivre mais alors quelle serait la
solution attention à ce que le discours
de sascha kever alarmiste aujourd'hui
les ceux qui font la météo
il parle comme vous ils sont il parle
des grands mots kabila qui fait
franchement qui fait peur on a des
images
décidé depuis maintenant quelques jours
d'arrêter d'utiliser mon montant
habituel qui peaufinage je trouve un peu
au fur et à mesure des des mois un peu
nul c'est à dire de d'arriver en plateau
il vous dira la france va être concerné
par une nouvelle année et la cloche
je porte ça ne marche plus c'est à dire
que là il faut bien qu'on bien
comprendre que les il faut que les gens
comprennent que la france clairement va
cramer cette semaine il faut que les
gens se rendent compte que ce qui est en
train de se passer ça n'est que la face
cachée de l'iceberg alors quel est ce
qu'il faut être à ce point alarmiste et
qu'il faut c'est pas ça fait pas ça fait
peur oui on est en colère oui mais il ya
des choses à faire et oui il faut dire
la vérité aux gens faut pas le camoufler
derrière des eaux ça va être la pire
vague de chaleur de l'été où on va
devoir être en maillot de bain au
trocadéro c'est pas ça la réalité la
réalité c'est qu'on va mourir c'est que
toute ma jeune génération vos enfants on
est condamné à mort par le gouvernement
actuellement c'est ça qu'il faut dire
aux gens oui mais je sais bien d'être
alarmiste mais il faut aussi c'est la
réalité de ce qui va se passer l'accord
mais faute peut-être proposer des choses
sur lucio des solutions cette fois qu'on
a dit il va faire chaud et on va tous
crever on n'a pas fait avancer la chose
répond karine nous pourrons penser que
c'est trop tard ou quoi ah non c'est pas
trop tard du tout on a plein d'actions à
mener à plein d'action qui sont donné
les ont fait sauter à l'eau traitement
alors au niveau local il faut pas
négliger le niveau local chacun peut
agir pour sa ville sa nos collectivités
sont d'entreprise ya plein de solutions
évidemment faut réduire nos émissions de
gaz à effet de serre ça passe par des
rennais mais en plus il fait chaud on
met la clean comme un con mais la clim
on tire sur le court ans révolus courant
et que en ce moment c'est un peu le
board avec le pétrole et le feu
nucléaire est en panne mais bon on crame
du du charbon d'affaires énergétiquement
les bâtiments c'est la revendication
dernières innovations juste leur place
et riffs gelé venir mais la c1 c'est un
cercle sans fin ou pas reprocher aux
gens de se refroidir puisque j'ai vu un
médecin qui aime qui m'a dit une phrase
qui a l'air con comme ça mais qui m'a
dit en hiver quand il fait chaud froid
on se chauffe et on était quand il fait
beau jour on se demanderait si bien l
anrt penser aux gens de matelas clean
c'est un peu ce que le gouvernement a
fait en ligne au km 10 de frais mais que
les français maxime j'ai encore qu'ils
ont perdu en effet à l'elysée m
art très concrètes déjà pour limiter un
petit peu la hausse des températures
rapidement c'est la revégétalisation met
beaucoup plus de nature en ville
beaucoup plus d'arbres de végétaux
sauvegarder les prairies naturelles les
points d'eau c'est quelque chose qu'on
ne fait pas assez que certains pays du
monde font et on commence à peine à
faire en france ben à paris la maire de
paris pour l'instant fait des travaux
il sera notre dossier mais oui dans les
mosquées les bonnes comprendre c'est
concrètement moi à titre personnel
qu'est-ce que je peux changer dans mes
habitudes le matin ou au quotidien ou de
chaque semaine pour changer les choses
est ce que je peux encore faire quelque
chose ou pas car exacte devrait
comprendre oui oui bien sûr on peut tous
faire quelque chose et c'est la
multiplication ces petites actions qui
va avoir un impact sur la france et sur
le monde évidemment ce qu'on peut faire
et bien déjà c'est au niveau énergétique
consommer moins avoir des énergies plus
propres on peut utiliser moins sa
voiture privilégier le télétravail en
ile-de-france ces surcharges et moi je
pense qu'on devrait vraiment renforcer
le télétravail on empile de police
aujourd'hui je suis désolé de vous
couper mais moi ça me rend folle en fait
on est en train de parler de toute une
génération qui va mourir parce qu'elle
pourra plus nourrir et voilà en train de
parler de pas prendre l'a fait étape à
malaga
mais bien sûr mais moi je
sais c'est un an mais je suis là pour ça
que tu vas mourir
réalité en fait et on peut pas dire aux
gens
je suis un gouvernement a les clés en
main c'est lui qui le monde nous déjà
dire entre guillemets moi j'ai ma fille
qui vont grade ok tu vas tu vas mourir
fait plus alors excusez moi on veut pas
mourir très clairement on veut me faire
peur et dans son enfance alors que les
enfants qui sont faits pour être heureux
son papy un charles aurait donc on n'a
pas choisi dans l'attaqué dans laquelle
on maintenant mais je
les ai tous
heureux donc c'est quoi votre solution
puisque vous allez vous avez l'air de
connaître le sujet est vraiment bravo
mais c'est quoi votre solution
aujourd'hui pour que moi qu'ils à ma
fille ce soir ma chérie pour que tu as
bien pour tous soit plus heureuse et
bien tu ne vas plus faire ça et tu peux
faire ça ce que je peux dire qu'à part
la guerre civile en fait voyager vous
arrêtez vous aujourd'hui oui pourquoi
est-ce que vous avez droit de voter
parce qu'il ya des femmes qui se sont
battus dans l'histoire qu'elle occupe
aujourd'hui un espace nouveau joueur de
l'équipe messieurs
des questions allez on leur a dit le
gouverneur qui permet de parler comme ça
c'est ridicule la guerre c'est contre
productif est d'aujourd'hui n'ont pas
déjà mennucci pas alarmiste de nagy
la réalité de ce qui est en train de se
passer
bc avec des discours pour qu'elles
soient justement que vous aller
inquiéter les gens non non c'est ces
gens faisant la guerre c'est vrai qu'on
attend attend alors les attend s'ils
devenaient sur rien consacre une
perturbation le gouvernement il faut
qu'il réagisse qu'il a les clés en main
il sait qu il
nous dit
on a besoin de comprendre nous nous
sommes tous responsables mais parce qu
on peut changer
rénovation des pressions soient
écoutés malhao non mais qu'est ce qu'on
dit alors que cette part et nos bases on
attendait rénover une maison bbc
peut pas non plus dire 'faites fait des
travaux mettent nommé bt des cloisons
refaites le toit mais des fenêtres
isotherme ça coûte une blanc atomique
donc ça s'est passé vous pensez que
c'est un choix politique de m c'est un
choix politique de la découverte en mai
sais pas si c'est un propos qu'elle
travaille c'est s'amuser sur le climat a
fait tout un discours devant les
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments les
experts le savent les experts ça fait
déjà 30 ans qu'on parle de ça nos
solutions on les a le gouvernement les
connaît donc aujourd'hui c'est à nous
citoyens et citoyennes
moi je gère 50 mesures de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat ont été
proposées au gouvernement je passais
vous seulement réalisé les jeux à grand
pas par exemple la rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments je
suis il n'y a pas qu'à ça ce n'est pour
dire comment ça un moment donc moi mon
but aujourd'hui c'est de mettre pression
sur le gouvernement et le faire réagir
écoutez bien mais rentrée venez
sacha les faire car je vais fêter la
même chose en fait excusez moi je vous
avais deux mais vous avez vous avez deux
idées vous dites il faut il faut rénover
les bâtiments et on va tous mourir comme
ça star laissez pas péril pour entrer en
résistance avec un discours un peu un
peu agresse un peu un peu guerrier vous
dis franchement après ce qu'on a vécu
entre le coni avait dégénéré compagnie
avoir un discours qui
encourage à cela se révolte et robert
waseige touche moi
savoir alors il ya prise et
magali on n'est pas au café du commerce
mais plus je dépassais sont dangereuses
et moi personnellement nous envoie à
l'abattoir c'est le challenge
de secondes les séparant insupportable à
face à l'impression que je trouve ça
super que vous soyez un coup de coin
alors oui je trouve ça super que vous
soyez à la remise parce qu'il faut être
alarmiste parce que si on continue comme
ça voilà ce qui va se passer
effectivement va tous mourir sans doute
de ça de manière prématurée il ya une
génération qui va mourir donc ça je
trouve ça très bien donc arrêtons de
nous boucher les oreilles en revanche
maintenant mademoiselle pour qu'on
comprenne bien et pour peu soyez audible
pour tout le monde si vous avez quelque
chose à dire à l'état au gouvernement
c'est quoi concrètement c'est quoi
et ce avec ça il nous appelle là c'est
tous les jours pour 1 euro mais
concrètement juste concrètement qu on
comprenne et comme ça on fédère grave
avec vous en faites aujourd'hui je suis
d'accord merci beaucoup aujourd'hui il
faut bien commencer quelque part on n'a
pas le temps de se gratter les jouets
les fenêtres sont appauvris n'a en fait
jamais
sa présence est d'accord mais sacha
voulais quelque chose de
travailler
avec nous on est là des mannala les
locaux mais juste pour demander à
thierry ce que vous
voulez juste élargir au delà de la
rénovation d'acheter des bâtiments bah
oui le gouvernement macro nommé pour
aller au delà justement parce que vont
briller au n'est pas restée
là dedans au delà de ça c'est pas le cas
mais c'est juste que 150 propositions
ont été faites par les
sons gouverne mais la confiance règne
pour le climat ça va au delà des
rénovations par contre 1 voilà donc une
proposition de l'ue d'aider des mesures
concrètes
l'elysée la commission skype si on
allonge mademoiselle quelles sont les
propositions concrètes et agressions
revu les
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
images d une barre google comme support
karine rousseau qui passent toujours ça
va mal se passer alors carine bronard
terrible traitement karine à part foncée
mét naître quelques chauffeurs pour
améliorer tout ça alors comme j'ai dit
des initiatives locales pour voir sa
ville pour son entreprise revégétaliser
c'est quelque chose vraiment que c'est
en une solution d'avenir ce qu'on
appelle fondée sur la nature de la
solution d'avenir pour plusieurs raison
garder on sait bien que les zones vérité
sont plus fraîches sans le sait tous
mais aussi plus de végétaux sa stocks
plus de carbone dans le sol alors c'est
pas la seule solution il faut quand même
réduire nos émissions de gaz à effet de
serre on n'y coupera pas mais c'est vrai
que en utilisant la nature en utilisant
les végétaux on va vraiment stocker
davantage de carbone et ça ça peut
vraiment je suis certains vont vous dire
le temps qu'on plantes les arbres le
temps qu'on fait ça il va se passer
prendre
sur nous aimons pression de personne n'a
lu cette convention parce que vous vous
répéter la même chose vous vous répétez
baumann truc donc vous c'est
l'immobilier et puis vous c'est la
nature est ce que quelqu'un est
ce que la régie à ces propositions qu'on
regarde et qu'on parle en ce sens pour
trouver la question est ce que là il ya
une personne qui a une idée d'un plan
super on va à la fois avoir des
transports de l'énergie etc tous super
parfait là dans les deux à trois ans qui
nous restent parce qu'on se rappelle les
1020 turquie avait subi ce genre
d'analysé est ce que quelqu'un non mais
juste est ce que quelqu'un aujourd'hui à
une meilleure option mais je vais plus
loin que vous aimez ou d'où vous sortez
ce mille bouddhas dans trois ans certes
dans trois ans si je vous écoute dans
trois ans et donc de répondre à ma
question est ce que aujourd'hui on a
même des personnes qui nous écoutent
juste remettez-vous un peu question est
ce que aujourd'hui quelqu'un mais un
meilleur contrôle et une solution
m'adresse à vous avertir permet
d'enfermer ces super d2 dire que jamais
l'innovation mais c'est pas le cas mais
je sais qu'il espère que la rénovation
je me suis entendu dire non mais fabrice
et de la convention
non mais c'est pas parce que votre
discours évidemment qui est important
mais il faut faire attention ce que en
voulons en faire enfin une façon de
parler aux gens et je te voilà je vous
dit c'est toujours pareil on culpabilise
les gens
oui d'accord mais la boue les ont bien
peu 20 minutes de retard sur le match
mais
[Rires]
moi je trouve ça très bien d'être
engagés sur quatre est bien de défendre
des idées on sait à quel point
l'écologie est censé les on sait tous
que si on ne fait rien voilà on va avoir
des regrets mais je gérais gmail a nommé
si j'aimerais que votre discours soit au
lieu de cela vous nous faites les gens
mais que vous nous emmenez avec vous
plutôt que vous nous renvoyez face à
face c'est tout à fait vrai ça toi
changes after the stars mais honnêtement
il faut être plus il va la vie on
reproche souvent aux écolos adana dette
d'adp est d'aller trop loin et puis on
les écoutait faudrait s'éclairer à la
bougie mais c'est vrai parfois faut pas
aller trop loin dans dont elle est trop
lent que demandait la rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments
[Applaudissements]
savais pas que j'étais alors juste j'ai
compris la rénovation du bâtiment on est
tous d'accord ça je pense et on va y
voit partout des arbres aussi juste et
ce qui est des 2/3 quelque chose ou on
pourrait donner comme quoi
un numéro vert déjà nommé robert numéro
azur vous allez mourir
voilà c'est non mais ça c'est pour la
canicule évidemment
0 800 06 66 66 voilà
pour moi quand j'étais petit on mettait
des draps mouillés sur les fenêtres par
exemple aurait coupé la chaleur on
prenait un saut de glace et on mettait
le brun ventilo ça fait de l'air tout
serait resté fermé toute la journée
ça va pas je sais que ça va pas arranger
les choses tout de suite mais les gens
qui nous regardent d'abord ils ont très
chaud ils n'ont pas tous la clim et vous
l'aimerez conseil et ils veulent des
conseils et c'est vrai que nos hivers au
oui non mais faisant de la résistance
civile toute la journée marché qu'est ce
que vous allez faire mais c'est
insupportable
c'est
dur
[Applaudissements]
mais si je dois me dire d'aller faire la
guerre tous les genres fait sa maman
mais a comme ça vous dire moi j'ai un
fils de 10 ans je veux qu'ils disent est
jolie mais vivent dans un même si mes
cheveux qu'ils savent montrer le
meilleur mais je vais pas l'envoyer en
sorte à gênés devant les buts et je me
tâte soit à roland garros
le récit des mois elle devait mois
ils seront accompagnés d'accord si vous
chantez qui ne sont pas d'accord
neureuther